المشهد بات متشابها امام المدارس الحكوميه
التونسيه اولياء امور غاضبون محتجون
يطالبون بحق ابنائهم في التعليم المهدد في
ظل غياب المدرسيهم فا منذ بدايه السنه
الدراسيه الحاليه يخوض الاف المدرسين
المدلاء في تونس اضرابا مفتوحا تسبب في
اغلاق العديد من المدارس في البلاد وعدم
التحاق الالاف من التلاميذ بمقاعدهم
الدراسيه هؤلاء المدرسون المؤقتون الذين
امنوا سنوات عده في موقع البديل وبرواتب
زهيده يطالبون وزاره التربيه والتعليم
بادماجم في الوظيفه بشكل الرسميه وفوري
الطلاب خارج مقاعد الدراسه هم الخاسر
الاكبر طبعا المزيد مع مراسلتنا في تونس
الاحلام العبدليه
لم يتمتع نحو 400 الف التلميذ من تلاميذ
التعليم الاساسي بالعوده المدرسيه في عدد
من المحافظات التونسيه الى تاريخ اليوم
رغم مروري ما يقارب الشهرين على التحاق
زملائهم بفصول الدراسه
ازمه غير مسبوقه اندلعت بعد اندلعت نقابه
التعليم الاساسي المدرسين النواب الى عدم
الالتحاق بمراكز عملهم في المدارس الى حين
تسويه وضعهم المهني من قبل وزاره التربيه
والغاء عقود التشغيل الهشام وبسبب اقفل
باب الانتدابات كانت الوزاره
في المدرسين الجدد في المرحله الابتدائيه
مع عقود تشغيل هشه تعتمدها منذ سنوات لسد
حاجه القطاع من المدرسين
تتعارض العقود التي منحتها الوزاره مع
النظام الاساسي للمهنه وتمنح المعلمين
النواب تقريبا نصف الراتبي الذي يحدث به
زملائهم المنتدبون وفقا لقوانين العمل في
القطاع الحكومي
[موسيقى]
لم تنجح جلساته التفاوض بين وزاره التربيه
و نقابه التعليم الاساسي في الوصول الى حل
النقابه تتمسك بالتسويه التامه والوزاره
تتواعد بالتسعيد خاصه ان المهله التي
منحتها للمدرسين للالتحاق بمراكز العمل قد
انتهت
يقف الظرف الاقتصادي هو عائقا امام
الانتدابات في القطاع الحكومي وترفض
النقابات واستغلال منظورها والانتقال من
حقوقهم في حين يقبع الاف التلاميذ في
منازلهم يترصدهم شبح الجهل في بلد طالما
رهنا على التعليم وعلى المصعد الاجتماعي
الى صباح العربيه احلام العبدلي تونس
عمار عزيز عمار يسعد صباحكم معنا يعني
الاف الطلاب تونسيين خارج
المدارسين العمل لكن في نهايه الامر اللي
يتعلق بازمه في في التعليم حيث جوده
التعليم او كفاءته وانما
التبول النقابات حقوق الموظفين ايضا وال-
همم انحسار الموارد الماليه التي تمر بها
الموازنه في في تونس لكن من حيث الجوده
التعليم التونسي وارثه
لا يتعلق بها
سنتطرق في سياق حديثنا الى مساله جوده
التعليم التونسي اليوم مخلفات حكم الاخوان
في تونس استدعت معها الاسماء الاقتصاديه
لكن اليس من الاولى التركيز بالدرجه
الاولى على التعليم لخلق بيئه بيواعيه
باغلى تكون حاضنه لمساله الارهاب
والاخوانهم
من ناحيه الموارد لم يتغير الامر منذ
السنه الاولى للاستقلال في تونس الموارد
الاكثر تذهب الى
موازنه التربيه والتعليم لكن هناك ازمه
اقتصاديه دوليه هناك ظرف دوليه هو الذي
يعيق تلبيه كل الرغبه وايضا هناك بعض
الاسباب التي تتعلق بالمشهد السياسي عامه
من ناحيه الارهاب وغيره تونس ودعت الارهاب
منذ سنوات طويله لما نسمع بمثل هذه
التهديدات في سنوات الاخيره طيب عمار قلت
ان الازمه اليوم في بس لا تشمل جوده
التعليم وكفاءته لا نتحدث عن تاريخ قطاع
التعليم المشرق في تونس المعروفين المنطقه
التعليم في تونس يهودي الى همم قرون طويله
منذ تاسيس جامعه زيتونه من سنه 689
ميلاديه من جامعه الزيتونه همم مثلا جاء
افرد ذلك التونسي هم الذين بنواهم مثلا
الازهر في القاهره جوهر الثقيل هو هو من
بنى ايضا همم جمع القرويين فيها المغرب
تونسيه فاطمه الفهري من هذا القرفه
التعليمي تخرج ابن خلدون رائد علم
الاجتماع ايضا الامام سحنون ايضا محمد ابن
عرفه الذي حرم العبوديه منذ 500 سنه قبل
البريطانيين وقبل الامريكان هي منظومه
صلبه ظل التعليم يستند الى الدين حتى سنه
1840 عندها تاسست مدرسه بارد وهي مدرسه
البوليتكنيك هي مدرسه بتخريج اطارات
الدوله منها تخرج الوزير الاكبر خير الدين
التونسي رائد النهضه والذي اصبح لاحقا هو
الوزير الاول للامبراطوريه العثمانيه من
اسطنبول تخرج منها عبد العزيز جاويشه
التونسيه رائد النهضه في في مصر استمر هذا
الامر حتى سنه 1865 عندما تاسست المدرسه
الصديقيه واسسها خير الدين ايضا واا هذه
هي المدرسه هي التي افرزت الجيل الذي بنى
دوله تونسيه وراء يده الحبيب برجيبه مع
سنه الاستقلال 1956 تم او عهد بملف
التربيه للشقيق شاعر تونس الذي كان شعره
يكون وحيا ابو القاسم الشابي شقيقه الاصغر
محمد الامين الشابي هو الذي اسس منظومه
التعليم ثم لاحقا محمود المصعد كان اديبا
كان في العشرينات من عمره وهو الذي اسس
التعليم على اساس الاختلاط بين البنات
اولاد المساواه التامه ايضا ان يكون
التعليم علمانيه ان يكون اجباريا الزاميا
وايضا مجانيا لكن هناك ايضا التاريخ يحفظ
مساهمه كبيره لوزير الخارجيه ورئيس
الوزراء العراقي الراحل وهو الفاضل الجميل
فاضل الجمالي لو تسمحوا لي هي قصه جديده
بالاستماع لان سنه 48 عندما ذهب برجيبه
الى الامم المتحده لعرض قضيه المغرب
العربي هناك كان الحراس يدفعونه عن مقر
الامم المتحده كانت بصدد تاسيس ومن يشرف
على التاسيس كان فاضل للجمالي كان وزير
الخارج العراق وهو الذي البس برجيبه شاره
الدخول وقال له انك عضو الوفده العراقيه
اليوم فتفضل همم دخل برجيبه عرض القضيه
التونسيه ثم استقلت تونس سنه 56 وحكم على
فاضل جمالي بالاعدام في العراق كان رئيس
وزراء ثم همم طلع
فاضل جمالي ونفي همم مفر الى تم العفو عنه
خرج الى سويسرا هناك عام الى مترجمه وفجاه
لاحدا مندوب التونسي انفاض الجمالي يعمل
لاجئا في الامم المتحده في سويسرا
فاستدعاه الحبيب بورقيبه الى تونس ومنحه
الجوازات التونسي ومنذ ذلك العام اصبح
مدرسا اصبح من اشهر المدرسين في تونس وهو
الذي ربط العلاقات بين الحكومه التونسيه
والحكومه العراقيه التي موتت التعليم
العالي في تونس بنات الكثير من الجامعات
بنات الكثير وهمم كانت تطبع كل همم كل
الكتب بعد مثلا اغلب الكتب التي همم درست
بها كان مكتوب عليها هديه من الشعب العراق
الى شقيقه التونسي همم المنظومه كانت
منظومه علمانيه ومنظومه كانت ال- ال- تقوم
على ال ال الاختلاط وايضا على العلمانيه
مثلا بالنسبه الى التدريس الدين
يدرس القران يدرس في سياقاته هي التاريخيه
بما يسمح للتلميذ بان يبني رايه والخاص لا
السيطره الفكريه التي يمكن ان تذهب به
بعيدا في الامور الاديولوجيه عمار نحن
نشكر الجزيره
للمنظومه التعليميه الصلبه في تونس شكرا
لك الصحفي المتخصص في شان التونسي عمار
عزيز شكرا عمار